hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
evaluation of micronaut s anaerobes mic
broth micro dilation panels with a large
collection of clinical samples
i'm alexis kraus of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
labberts and sponsored by brooker
daltonics
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website
at brooker.com so
let's get started i would like to remind
everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located
on the far left your screen i'd like to
now introduce our presenter
miriam cordovana scientist r d methods
development
microbiology and diagnostics broker
deltonics
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
miriam you may now begin your
presentation
welcome
thank you very much for this kind
introduction and i would like to thank
the organizers
for making this event possible so ladies
and gentlemen good afternoon
i am pleased to welcome you to this
webinar
my name is miriam cordovana and i come
from italy
i have worked in the bacteriology
section of the university hospital of
bologna
polyclinic santorum for 13 years
dealing with routine practice and
research products
in the field of bacterial antibiotic
resistance
previously i had worked at the
university hospital career
garage in flores in clinical
microbiology
and in the human genetic department in
may i have joined the r d department of
broca's electronic in bremen
and today i am glad to present in this
webinar
a study that i performed when i was in
bologna
regarding the evaluation of the
micronaut system for susceptibility
testing of anaerobes
which types of infections can be caused
by anaerobes
anaerobic bacteria are a fundamental
component of healthy microbiota of skin
gut genital tract oral cavity
and in general of all mucous membranes
infections caused by anaerobes can
involve virtually any organ
and can have a very different clinical
presentation and severity
anaerobic infections can be divided in
exogenous infections
endogenous infections and unusual
infections
exogenous infections are mainly caused
by members of the genus clostridium
and are acquired by intake ingestion
wounds from the outside of bacterial
spores
contaminated food or environment the
most common are clostridium diffusive
diarrhea
which poses serious issues in hospital
hygiene control
botulism and tetanus which can be little
if not
promptly promptly treated more commonly
anaerobic infections are endogenous
often polymicrobial
caused by the invasion of the sterile
body sites
by anaerobes belonging to normal flora
which can turn into pathogens
once out of their habitat they involve
more frequently abdomen
pelvis skin and soft tissues overall
cavity and wounds
and they can be severe and lead to
sepsis
moderately anaerobes are the causative
agents of serious
pulmonary infections in seistic
fibrosis patients as well as in patients
carrying prosthetic joints plants
they can also cause chronic genital
infections and
infections in following animal bites
anaerobic infections represent a burden
for clinical microbiology diagnostics
and the role of anaerobes as causative
agents of
severe infections despite well-known
is still nowadays neglected and
underestimated
this especially due to the fact that
they are traditionally fastidious to
process
handle and testing clinical microbiology
routine
as they are often slow growing and
require dedicated incubation conditions
they pose problems from the moment of
sampling to transport
to cultivation resulting in a lab
intensive diagnosis
and a long and long term around time
in most laboratories worldwide
antibiotic susceptibility testing of
anaerobes is performed only for selected
cases
as an as an example blood cultures or
monomicrobial samples
while the other cases are reported as
mixed infections
and the antibiotic treatment is based on
empiric choice
despite the incidence of anaerobic
infections remains relatively low
they are still associated with high
mortality rates
more an increasing trend in antibiotic
resistance has been
observed in the last years with also an
increasing number
of multi-drug resistance reports
therefore susceptibility pattern of
anaerobes
is always less predictable and the
empiric treatment has become no longer
satisfactory
one side of the burden of anaerobic
infections regards the mortality rate
in this study the authors compared a
28-day mortality
rate between patients properly treated
and patient not
properly treated and the results are
shown in the graphic on the right
as we can see in the graphic on the left
the survival rate
the survival rate resulted higher in
those patients
who underwent an appropriate antibiotic
treatment
while it drops significantly not
properly treated patients
fever is really high highly significant
this findings proves that an empiric
antibiotic treatment
based on the standard guidelines is no
more satisfactory
and it is really really important to
investigate antibiotic susceptibility
of the single anaerobes isolates
another side of the burden of anaerobic
infections regards the antibiotic
resistance rates
in this slide i reported the results of
the study performed by professor naji
and the ashmit study group for anaerobes
in which the authors compared the
resistance rates
reported in three different studies
performed over a 20 years period of time
this study shows a significant and
worrying increase
over the years in the resistance rates
for all the antibiotic molecules
investigated as an example um
widely used first-line antibiotics such
as
oxycodone cleveland aid and clindamycin
rose from one to
ten percent and from nine to thirty-two
percent with
respectively but even if lower
an increase was observed also for second
line antibiotics
such as imipenem
but after this background which is the
state of the art
of routine diagnostics
in the last years the introduction of
malditofems has greatly revolutionized
the diagnostics of anaerobes
in terms of identification at species
level
enabling to save up to two four days in
the reporting time
in comparison with a classical
biochemical mass
but currently ast remains still a gray
zone
for different reasons despite several
methods
available because most of them present
important drawbacks that makes them not
so amenable for daily routine
the reference method which is
aggregation
is not applicable for routine testing as
it is lab intensive
therefore it is restricted to a few
reference centers
this diffusion which is largely used for
other facilities bacteria
was shown not to be reliable for
anaerobes
the most commonly used method is
gradient diffusion test
but it is anyhow expensive and time
consuming
on the other side molecular methods
beyond expensive
have very limited applications for
anaerobes
currently those micro dilution despite
being considered a reference method
is recommended by clsi only for
bacteroides species
until evidence regarding its reliability
with
other species will be provided
nevertheless
two commercial systems are available the
micronut system and the substitute
system
which differ mainly for the broad used
for the inoculum
and the panel of antibiotics included
and now we come to the study that we
performed in blue
in bologna we evaluated the performance
of the micronaut as
anaerobe mic test panel with a
collection of clinical isolates
the micronaut panel is a standardized
growth microevolution method
performed in a 96 well microscopic plate
it contains lyophilized antibiotics and
it is suitable for both gram positives
and gram negatives
the micronut panel includes 13
antibiotics with
proven activity against anaerobes
covering all the antibiotic classes
recommended by eukast and clsi
as an example penicillins beta-lactams
plus
beta-lactamase inhibitors combinations
herbals fluoroquinolones that are
cyclists etc
each antibiotic is present in a broad
range of concentrations
most of antibiotics have eight to four
dilutions
while vacuum myosin has three and
tetracycline
s4 and they enable the determination of
mic values and their interpretation
accordingly both to eucas
or to clsi breakpoints
to inoculate a panel a modified wilkins
children growth
is used which is pre-reduced before the
use
to better support the growth also of the
most fastidious anaerobic species
now let's take a look at the study
design more in details
overall 300 not duplicate clinical
isolates were included
responding to 30 genera and 82 species
from the most common to less common ones
the strains were collected prospectively
from blood cultures
prosthetic joint infections abdominal
infections
and deep wound infections to achieve the
presence
of a higher number of different and less
common species
the number of bacteroides fragility the
most common anaerobic pathogen
was limited to the first 33 consecutive
isolates
the asd by micronaut was performed in
parallel with gradient test method
mic test strips using the same bacterial
suspensions for the inoculum of both
methods
all the procedures in this study were
performed on bench
and in air environment
the procedure to set up the test is
summarized in the pictures
from left to right briefly a 0.5
macvalen bacterial suspension
in 0.9 percent saline solution was
prepared
and 200 microliters of it were used to
inoculate the micron outpost
100 microliters of inoculated broth
were distributed in each well of the
panel with a multi-channel pipette
the painting was then sealed and
incubated at 37 degrees
in anaerobic environment for 20
for 24 to 72 hours after 24 hours of
incubation
the panels were visually inspected and
if a growth was
observed in the growth control well the
one
cycled in red in the image the mic
values were red the last picture on the
right shows a panel
in which a bacterius flagellus has grown
as it can be observed the antibiotics
are placed vertically
in the panel with the highest
concentrations in the upper part
mic strips test was performed following
manufacturer's instructions
using the same antibiotic molecules
a1 macralen suspensions and brucella
blood again
and here i summarize the results of the
study
mic results were interpreted using
yoga's breakpoint
updated to 2019
results delivered by the micronut panels
were compared with those of
mic strips and this ladder were taken as
reference method
despite it is not a reference method but
it was the lab standard method at the
time of the study
thus discrepancies between the two
methods could
actually be interpreted in both
directions
the performance of the micronaut panel
was evaluated in terms of agreement
essential in categorical and in terms of
error rates
according to iso recommendations
as you can see reported here in the
table on the left
the agreement between the two methods
was very good
overall higher than 95 percent
also the error rate was very good with
the majority of very measured error
21 out of 24 restricted to those
antibiotics through which one single
break point
is defined furthermore most of these
discrepancies
involved a tattoo through which the
breakpoint overlaps
with the epidemiological cut-off results
were also investigated in terms of
incubation time
required to observe a visible growth
independence
as it is reported in the table on the
right
nearly all the most clinically relevant
isolates
bacteroides clostridium but also a good
number of prevotella and phosphobacteria
grew in 24 hours overall
around the 75 percent of all strains
grew after 24 hours
while the most slow growing species
required 48 or 72 hours of equation
in addition for the most oxygen
sensitive species
such as pheromonas and the alistar
incubation was performed in an
environment
with a lower residual oxygen content
than standard
obtain using a double amount of
anaerobiosis generator
for 4 of these isolates it will it was
possible to observe a growth
only after 5 days of incubation
in conclusion to summarize results of
this study here we have that
all the isolates but one performance
successfully
agree in the micronut panels no problems
were
observed for gram-positive cocci in
contrast with the literature
as in some past studies a failure of
growth in the micro dilution system
was reported for this group of anaerobes
and this is also one of the reasons for
which this method is recommended by clsi
at the moment only for bacterias
most of the isolates included delivered
a result
after 24 hours of incubation and among
them
the vast majority of the most clinically
relevant ones
an excellent agreement with the lab
standard methods was found
and most of the discrepancies were
restricted to ectapanim
for which the uk's breakpoint is
surprisingly low
and overlaps with the epidemiological
cut-off
the micronauts system proved to be a
very user-friendly method
with a shorthand some time therefore it
proved to be suitable for routine
testing of
anaerobes
summarizing the study we can say that
the most recent data reported in the
literature
suggests that there is a need for robust
and reliable methods
for susceptibility testing of anaerobes
given the high mortality rate of
anaerobic infections
and given the increasing rate of
antibiotic resistance
also among these pathogens likely as a
consequence of the same selective
pressure
that led to the development of the more
famous resistance mechanisms
among aerobic bacteria different methods
have been described up to now
and are commercially available but each
one of them
shows some important drawbacks that
hampers their
large-scale implementation in clinical
microbiology lab
the findings of the study i have
presented here
show that the micronut panel represents
a reliable and user-friendly method
suitable for routine practice it fits
both with eocos and clsi recommendation
and including also second line
antibiotics
it provides a comprehensive results in
one single test
it is a universal system which showed to
support the growth of
all anaerobic species tested including
the most fastidious ones
in addition the fact that the micronaut
weakest charging growth
does not contain blood makes the system
free from reproducibility and
manufacturing issues
this fact together with a simplified
logistic
long shelf life forager at room
temperature
results in an easy of implementation in
clinical microbiology routine practice
and the method at the end combines the
features of reliability
of a reference method with the user
friendliness
for operators
a paper was published containing all
this data of
of the study and if you like you can
find all details and more information in
this webinar is part of a collection or
webinar series
of broker microbiology and diagnostics
in innovation and product
launches 2020 helping you achieve your
goals
you are welcome to join our next
webinars
and you can also watch the previous one
on the map
thank you for your attention and thank
you for attending this webinar
thank you miriam for that informative
presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started miriam our first
question is
how do you manage the workflow for
isolates that are not grown
after the 20 after the 24 hours
well for those isolates i think the
first 24 hours of incubation we anyhow
take a look
at the growth control well and if there
is growth
as i described in the webinar we go on
with the red reading the plate
but if there is no growth we simply um
incubate the plate again in the pouch or
in the jar or
whatever in whichever device we have
included a plate
so nothing nothing complicated to do
simply array incubate and continue
equation until the following day
perfect thank you so much for that
clarification so moving on to our next
question
so miriam how do you manage the
pre-reduction of the broth
okay the pre-reduction of the process um
the brush has to be pretty back redacted
for
at least three hours so in
for a routine practice workflow
you can just product them in the morning
as an example
uh you have to take
the brox tubes unscrew the caps
and incubate the tubes in anaerobic
environment
in order to let oxygen be removed
from the growth in the environment
anaerobic environment
and after that for you just put them
into in the
equator for the production
and after three hours you take them out
just screw them again and store
them ready to be used hopefully or
normally during the during the the daily
routine practice
and if they are not used during the same
day
in worst case can also be used the
following day because production is and
how very
let's say it works any one day
does not enable to to recover
all the oxygen content which was removed
so it's very user friendly again
perfect thank you so much so we do have
time for a few more questions but i do
just want to remind our audience that
those questions we are unable to answer
today
and those that do come in during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
miriam via the email address that you
provided at the time
of registration so
miriam let's move on to our next
question are there
any are there any limitations regarding
species
in this study all the species they were
included
grew in the brows and of course with the
with the time of inclusion which depends
on the features of the species which is
not so much related to the method itself
by
but from from species features
as since we compared two methods
in one was agar based uh
what did not grow on in the micronaut
panels did not even grow
in the agar we observed a perfect
correspondence
in terms of um time of growing
so therefore i'm i found no limitation
in terms of species
only as i mentioned for very oxygen
sensitive species
like such as perfurmonas and the alistar
i use this double amount of vanity
generation because these species are
really really
sensitive also to few minutes of
exposure exposure to oxygen
so but i would suggest to test to try
to test and to use them with any species
because i saw
personally we saw no limitation so
as far as we as we went on with our
study
perfect thank you so much so miriam
what is your impression on the um
excuse me let me start that over what is
your impression on the performance of
wilkins children broth as it does
not contain blood
well in my personal experience we can
i can see that media containing blood
flow
anaerobes makes routine practice not so
i'm enabled for for operators
because each time you use a brusella
and blood-based medium you have to take
care to the temperature of the
of the medium and to the plate to
humidity of the meat of
the on the plate you have to take care
that hemolysis have not
occurred so let's say that this wasn't
much much easier to
to be handled and to be used in
in a real life high throughput
laboratory i could say so we
it is exactly like to use another browse
like munirington or bh
brain heart infusion broth and so on
perfect thank you so much miriam so we
did get a we do have a couple more
questions in the queue
um let's go ahead and take a look and
see
which one uh which one you would like to
answer next
okay perfect uh let's you know what
let's do this one miriam
so and excuse me if i mispronounce
anything
how do gram positives as c acnes or
f magna behave with this panel
we have no problems with none of these
pieces
in most cases coty bacterium acnes grow
in
and also in 40 um sorry in the 24
24 hours while finna go
in some cases in 24 in other cases in 48
but
we observe any and we observed no
failure of growth for none of these
species
to the degree
without any problem perfect
and you know uh let's move on to this
one
now how do you play out your mixed
qualities
do you do singles because i think they
are
other organisms that are present in the
plates or specimen type
yes sure many of these samples were
polymicrobial samples
especially the ones coming from wounds
and we
just perform subcultures of
every of isolated colony in order to
have a pure
subculture and from the pure subculture
we
performed suitability testing so we were
sure after
after identification of species level of
course so we were sure it was a pure
culture and we checked the species
identification before
uh cuttering before subcatering and
after
subcatering so immediately after the
immediately before uh studying up
susceptibility testing
so we were sure not to have mixed
cultures or
misclassifications misidentification
wonderful thank you so much miriam and
just to
remind our audience again you know any
questions that we don't have time for
today
or those that may need a little bit more
research or those that come on
come in during the on demand period they
will be addressed uh
via your email address when you register
for
our webinar today so moving on to
our next question so miriam how
important it is to work with agar of
sheet blood
some of our users are growing their
bacterias on different media
before the ast test
and in my experience
um i in my former lab
we also used horse blood agar not only
blood agar but in in this study we used
[ __ ] blood dagger because we had to do
something standardized
for the publication but from my point of
view from my previous experience
there should be no difference between
between other
blood based argus agars at least no
differences between
sheep and horse pladaga as far as
it is my experience in my years in
bologna
so i i would suggest just to try
uh maybe just a couple of samples with
with comparison with horse and sheep but
i'm quite sure to expect
no differences in the in the performance
of the method
because it's any high enough selective
media and as far as bacteria
grow they are in a good fit let's see
wonderful thank you so much um
so we may have time for
just a couple more questions if any of
the audience members want to throw some
questions in for miriam today while we
still have her
but um in the meantime we want to thank
you again miriam you know do you
as we're waiting for a couple questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience
yes they have yeah yeah yeah yes
yes if you want to if you want to go
ahead and let our audience know what
uh what those are and give the audience
a second to see if they have any last
minute questions for you
any questions i am here to reply i still
have
time
no worries to anybody who is listening
to this presentation on demand you'll
still be able to
submit questions um via uh
over to miriam if you would like um oh
here's here's a question so now is there
any
instrumentation needed to run these
plates or
could we buy them separately
oh no we we just um we just used no
no instrument for this panels and we
we just use them and i'm hopefully this
should be implemented into the routine
in bologna in the next
weeks after the tenor and we just
we just decided to buy the panels
separately from any kind of possible
instant
instrument just by panels and roads
and to read everything manually
perfect and looks like we got another
question that just came in
now how is the performance of the
micronaut compared to the vipec
anaerobic card
um i i don't know because we in my
former lab we
despite we had the writing instrument
we decided not to use the anaerobic cuts
because we found them not so reliable
sorry to say but
from our former experience
we decided to use anaerobs
and gradient diffusion method
and then hopefully move to microsolution
but not light again as method
okay thank you so much for that miriam
all right oh we do want to thank the
audience
for the questions and for joining us
today
it was a great presentation thank you so
much miriam
and just again as a reminder you know
questions that we don't have time for
those submitted during the on-demand
period that all be addressed via the
contact information that you provided
at the time of registration
miriam here's another one so is the
micro not much better than this
um than the sens sen centair i'm sorry i
can't pronounce that word excuse me
um i cannot i cannot tell which is
better than the other because i
i i did not trust the sensitizer
but what my feeling is that
of course sensitization is also a good
method because it is a micro evolution
based but since the pros that they use
is blue cellar blood agar
so it contains blood
and maybe can be
can it has to be evaluated to see which
is the performance
with gram neck with ground positive
cocci which are the trickiest part of
of the bacteria i think that
this this throw evaluation has not been
been performed yet so what i can say
is is that micro networks micro nut
panels work
with uh any species i tested
but i can i don't have experience about
the sensitizer with the exception of
what i
read in the literature
and moving on to our next question so if
reading is done manually
how do you maintain a con consistency in
reading
by a different lab technician
yes for a subset of samples the first
i read the pennies myself but i also
ask another one of two persons to read
them
independently and then we just
one blind from the other and we just
then compared the results of our reading
[Music]
and this i did this for the first 53
for the other the most tricky ones the
most difficult
in which the the growth was more faint
and weak i i continued
doing this also until the end of the day
of the experiment
i always ask somebody else
beyond me one or two persons to read the
most tricky panels and then we compared
and in very few cases we observe a
difference of
one dilution step between one reading
and the other
and it was never significant in terms of
categorical agreement so it seems to be
also really robust
and not operator depending
perfect thank you so much so we do want
to thank
uh thank miriam again for her time today
and her important research we'd also
like to thank
leopards and our sponsor broker deltonix
for underwriting today's
educational webcast so before we go we
uh you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now everyone please join
us next week
for part five of our webinar series
which is fast typing
and classification of streptococcus
pneumoniae
and hygiene relevant strains we look
forward to seeing you then
until next time everyone stay safe stay
healthy
bye bye everyone
you